>> A SOCIALISM CONVENTION THIS
WEEKEND DONE IT GO EXACTLY AS
PLANNED.
THE SELF-PROCLAIMED COMRADES GOT
TOGETHER TO DEFEAT CAPITALISTS.
BUT THAT EVENT DESCENDED.
>> PERSONAL PRIVILEGE.
GUYS, FIRST OF ALL, JAMES
JACKSON FROM SACRAMENTO.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, CAN WE
PLEASE KEEP THE CHATTER TO A
MINIMUM?
I'M ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT'S
VERY, VERY PRONE TO SENSORY
OVERLOAD.
IT'S MAKING IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO FOCUS.
>> PERSONAL PRIVILEGE.
PLEASE DO NOT USE GENDERED
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS EVERYONE.
>> Greg: WOW.
DO KNOW WHAT THAT GUY NEEDS?
HE NEEDS A DOUBLE SHOT.
I DISAGREE WITH HOW YOU START
THIS.
THAT WENT EXACTLY AS PLANNED.
THANK GOD.
WHAT GREAT COMIC RELIEF.
WE NEEDED THIS SEGMENT.
I SALUTE THEM WITHOUT GENDERED
LANGUAGE.
THE WAVY ARMS, THE STUTTERING
BETA MALE.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO GET OUT MORE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO TO A
LIBERTARIAN CONVENTION.
THERE ARE 32 NATIONAL PARTIES.
ALL OF THESE CONVENTIONS ARE
INTERESTING, BECAUSE THEY BRING
AMERICANS FROM DIFFERENT POINTS
OF VIEW TOGETHER.
STAY ONE THAT'S ONE POINT OF
VIEW.
>> GUESS WHAT, I WILL NEVER
ATTEND ONE.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS AN ACTUAL SOCIALIST.
I THINK THAT WAS A CONSERVATIVE
COMEDIAN PRETENDING TO BE A
SNOWFLAKE SOCIALISTS.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN REAL.
>> THAT WAS A SET UP.
>> Greg: POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE.
THAT IS REAL.
>> Dana: THE ONE THING,
THOUGH, I WILL PROBABLY NEVER BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND IT.
I DO THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT THESE GUYS ARE DOING RIGHT.
THEY HAVE MORE PEOPLE
IDENTIFYING WITH THEM.
MAYBE NOT AFTER THEY WATCH THAT
CLIP, BUT THERE'S SOMETHING
HAPPENING ON THE GRASS ROOTS
PERSPECTIVE.
I WOULDN'T COUNT THEM OUT.
>> Jesse: NOW THAT I THINK
ABOUT IT, YOU HAVE SENSORY
OVERLOAD PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A SOCIALIST.
>> I HAVE SENSORY OVERLOAD.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> WE SHOULD SEND PEOPLE TO
MARDI GRAS.
HOW ABOUT THAT.
THESE PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW HOW TO
HAVE FUN.
COULD YOU IMAGINE WORKING WITH
SOMEBODY LIKE THAT IN YOUR
OFFICE?
I DON'T THINK THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
REAL LIVES, BECAUSE NONE OF THAT
STUFF AT WORK.
>> WORK FROM HOME.
>> WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS A
SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE WITHOUT USING
GENDER PRONOUNS.
>> CAN'T WE JUST ASSUME
SOMEONE'S IDENTITY?
>> Dana: A DEBATE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WHOEVER THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IS.
I COULD REWIND THAT 20 TIMES.
>> THAT'S WHO WE ARE.
>> Greg: THAT'S A DUMB IDEA.
WE AREN'T TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT A DUMB
IDEA.
THAT'S JUST A DUMB IDEA.
SOCIALISM KILLS PEOPLE.
IT KILLS MORE PEOPLE --
>> Dana: GENDER PRONOUNS.
>> THIS IS NOT THE PARTY OF
THOMAS JEFFERSON.
I CAN TELL.
>> WHY DID THEY THINK THAT'S
COOL?
THEY KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL GOING
TO HEAR THAT.
>> WHY NOT?
SEE WHEN HE PUT THE RAD IN
COMRADE.
>> Dana: BERNIE SANDERS IS NOT
THE NOMINEE.
WILL THEY ACTUALLY VOTE FOR A
DEMOCRAT IN THE ELECTION?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THE GREEN PARTY HAS MUCH
MORE OF AN INFLUENCE.
THE GREEN PARTY IN 2016 AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON.
I'M MORE AFRAID OF THE GREEN
PARTY IN TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY
TO DISRUPT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD BE AFRAID
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> NO I'M NOT.
YOU GUYS ARE BASICALLY DOING
YOURSELVES IN.
IF I CAN EXPLAIN THAT YOU AND 30
SECONDS.
I DON'T KNOW.